Imagínate estar en la guardia a las 3 de la mañana,
llega una paciente con un abdomen agudo, le pasas antibióticos de
amplio espectro, la dejas en observación pensando que tomaste la decisión
más segura del mundo.
Yo sé, te vas a descansar un rato creyendo que todo está bajo control.
Exacto, pero apenas 6 horas después, sus riñones están
en falla total y su presión arterial colapsa.
Hoy vamos a hacer un análisis a fondo de una pila de notas médicas
y literatura clínica de la Cátedra de Gastroenterología y Semiótica
Digestiva de la Universidad Central del Ecuador, específicamente del
Hospital Carlos Andrade Marín.
Sí, es un material fascinante porque no es sólo teoría, digamos.
Para nada. Nuestra misión hoy es diseccionar un caso socrático
superreal y extraer esos principios fisiopatológicos que
separan un diagnóstico de rutina de un error de juicio
letal. Vamos a ver cómo una decisión que parece 100%
correcta en la superficie termina desencadenando una catástrofe.
Es que el razonamiento clínico requiere ir mucho más allá de seguir un
algoritmo a ciegas.
En patología biliar, el peligro real es tratar una obstrucción mecánica
como si fuera, no sé, una simple infección de tejidos blandos.
Claro, esa desconexión conceptual.
Tal cual. Esa desconexión es lo que lleva al deterioro rápido de los pacientes en
urgencias.
Pues pongamos la viñeta exacta sobre la mesa para entender el problema.
Tenemos a una mujer de 58 años, con obesidad y antecedente
de dos embarazos. Llega con un dolor continuo en el hipocondrio derecho
de unas 30 horas de evolución.
Y ojo que ya había tenido episodios similares, ¿no?
Ajá, pero eran autolimitados.
Le duraban unas tres horas después de comer mucho y ya, se le pasaba.
Pero hoy el cuadro cambió drásticamente.
Tiene náusea severa, fiebre que empezó en la noche y escalofríos muy
fuertes.
Y aquí viene el detalle clave de la anamnesis, o sea, lo que enciende las
alarmas.
Los familiares notan algo, supongo.
Sí, dicen que desde ayer tiene los ojos amarillos.
Además, la paciente reporta orina oscura, como té, que clínicamente es
coluria,
Y heces pálidas, casi blancas, o sea, acolia, desde hace dos días.
Uf, esa descripción cronológica ya te traza un mapa impecable.
O sea, el dolor intermitente previo te sugería cólicos biliares simples.
Una piedrita que tapa y cae.
Exacto, una piedra que obstruye transitoriamente el conducto cístico.
Pero este dolor continuo de 30 horas, sumado a la fiebre y la ictericia, pues,
cambia el escenario por completo.
Totalmente. Físicamente sabemos que hay dolor y que se está poniendo amarilla.
Pero para saber si esto es solo una tubería bloqueada o ya es un incendio
sistémico, hay que ver los signos vitales.
Que son los que dictan la verdadera urgencia aquí.
Y fíjate en estos números. Tiene temperatura de 38.9 grados
centígrados, frecuencia cardíaca de 108 latidos por minuto y una
presión arterial que ya está raspando el límite inferior de 106
sobre 62 milímetros de mercurio.
Con esto, el margen de error es nulo.
Sí, esos signos estructuran una triada de Charcot de libro.
Dolor en hipocondrio derecho, ictericia y fiebre.
Ajá.
Pero lo que realmente debe asustar al que evaluó el caso es esa taquicardia y la
presión limítrofe. O sea, te están gritando que hay una respuesta inflamatoria
sistémica en marcha.
Ya no es solo la piedra atascada.
Para nada. Estamos ante una colangitis aguda.
Una infección purulenta en un sistema que maneja alta presión.
Vamos a desgranar un poco los mecanismos detrás de esto, porque a mí me parece
fascinante cómo algo tan básico como el color de la orina te revela
la anatomía microscópica.
Sí, es pura fisiopatología aplicada.
Esa coluria y acolia señalan directo a la bilirrubina
conjugada. ¿Por qué se da este cambio de colores tan específico?
Bueno, todo se reduce a la hidrostática y a las barreras celulares del hígado.
Normalmente, el hígado conjuga la bilirrubina, ¿no?
Y eso le da el color a las heces Exactamente, el color
marrón. Pero cuando un cálculo bloquea el colédoco, la bilis no pasa.
El resultado inmediato es la acolia, las heces claras Claro, se
quedan sin pigmento Pero el hígado sigue produciendo bilis.
Entonces, esa presión física dentro de los canalículos biliares aumenta
dramáticamente, hasta que termina rompiendo las uniones estrechas o las tight
junctions entre los hepatocitos.
O sea, es literal como si una tubería reventara y el agua se filtrara por las
paredes.
Esa analogía es muy precisa. Al romperse, esa bilirrubina conjugada
refluye directo a la sangre,
y como ya es hidrosoluble, viaja, llega a los riñones y se filtra hacia
la orina.
Y ahí tienes la orina como té, la coluria.
Así es. Y fíjate que este mecanismo te descarta rápido cosas como
una hemólisis o un síndrome de
Gilbert, porque ahí la bilirrubina elevada es indirecta, no se disuelve en agua
y jamás te
¡Qué buen dato!
Luego, en la exploración física confirmamos las escleras ictéricas y hay
dolor abdominal con defensa leve.
Al palpar profundo el reborde costal derecho, el dolor hace que corte la
respiración. Signo de Murphy positivo clásico.
Muy clásico.
Y otro hallazgo. Tiene escoriaciones en los brazos de tanto rascarse,
un prurito muy marcado.
Pero no hay estigmas de hepatopatía crónica, ni arañas vasculares,
ni ascitis.
Claro, porque el signo de Murphy te confirma mecánicamente que la vesícula está
inflamada y tensa. El diafragma baja, empuja la vesícula contra tu mano
y duele.
Ajá. ¿Y lo del prurito?
Lo del prurito agudo, sin signos crónicos, es el sello de la colestasis
obstructiva aguda. Las sales biliares no pueden salir, se acumulan en la piel y
te activan las terminaciones nerviosas.
Bueno, tenemos el cuadro clínico de obstrucción e infección.
Pero aquí llegan los laboratorios y hay un dato que es de fácil podría
desviar a cualquiera en una guardia llena.
A ver, ¿qué salió?
Los leucocitos en 17,800 con 88% de
neutrófilos, PCR en 18, bilirrubina total en 6,4
mg por decilitro con predominio directo de 4,9.
Todo eso cuadra súper bien.
Sí, es una colangitis de manual.
Pero, llega un reporte de lipasa en 95 unidades por
litro. O sea, ves una enzima pancreática elevada en un abdomen agudo
y el instinto te dice, un momento, esto podría ser una pancreatitis
aguda.
Uy, esa es una trampa analítica súper frecuente.
Hay que ser estrictos con los umbrales.
El límite superior normal, el LSN, de la lipasa en casi todos
los laboratorios para esto es de 60 unidades por litro.
Y tiene 95.
El
consenso
exige que la lipasa sea mayor a tres veces el límite superior normal para
diagnosticar pancreatitis aguda.
Entonces, si no es pancreatitis, ¿por qué demonios la lipasa está en 95?
Por la anatomía compartida, simplemente.
El colédoco y el conducto pancreático desembocan juntos en la ampolla de Vater.
Un cálculo ahí cerca, o el puro edema por la colangitis, aumenta la
presión en el conducto pancreático.
Ah, y eso lo irrita.
Exacto. Una irritación leve libera un poco de lipasa.
Pero el problema central es la vía biliar obstruida, no una
autodigestión pancreática primaria.
Ya veo. Y siguiendo con la bioquímica, hay otro punto de
confusión. Las transaminasas están elevadas, la ALT en 148
y la AST en 126.
Alguien podría decir que hay una hepatitis viral metida ahí.
Totalmente. Pasa mucho.
Y aquí el documento de la cátedra saca una herramienta matemática buenísima
para esto, que es el cálculo del cociente R.
Explícanos un poco el concepto.
El cociente R es una balanza.
Compara el daño a las células del hígado frente al daño a las tuberías biliares.
Tomas la ALT del paciente y la divides por su límite superior normal.
Luego haces lo mismo con la fosfatasa alcalina, que es el marcador biliar, y
divides ambos resultados.
O sea, si el problema es la plomería, domina la fosfatasa.
Tal cual.
Y si es un virus, domina la ALT.
Pues hagamos el cálculo con nuestra paciente.
Su ALT de 148 dividida por un límite de 40
nos da 3,7.
Perfecto.
Y su fosfatasa alcalina es de 410 contra un límite de 130,
eso da 3,15.
Entonces, 3,7 entre 3,15 nos da un
cociente R de aproximadamente 1,2.
¿Qué significa ese 1,2 en la vida real?
Un valor menor o igual a 2 define un patrón estrictamente colestásico.
O sea, las transaminasas altas no son por un ataque al hígado.
Son hepatocitos sufriendo estrés mecánico porque la bilis retenida los está
ahogando.
Si fuera hepatitis, ¿cuánto daría?
El cociente R se dispararía por encima de 5.
Así que la matemática te confirma que el hígado es sólo una víctima secundaria.
¡Qué buena forma de objetivarlo!
Bueno, con este mapa bioquímico súper claro, pasamos a la imagen.
La ecografía muestra una pared vesicular de 5 milímetros, que sabemos que
supera el límite normal de 4.
Y el colédoco está francamente dilatado en 11 milímetros, con
dilatación intrahepática.
Ahí ya tienes dos patologías coexistiendo.
Ajá.
Tienes la pared engrosada, que es colecistitis aguda litiásica.
Pero lo crítico es ese colédoco de 11 milímetros.
Un conducto normal mide hasta 6 milímetros, ¿no?
Y ella lo tiene casi al doble.
Sí. Esa dilatación con fiebre e ictericia te sella el diagnóstico de
colangitis aguda por coledocolitiasis.
Pero fíjate que el radiólogo anota algo que genera un punto ciego gigante.
Dice, no se logra visualizar el extremo distal del colédoco por
interposición de gas intestinal.
El clásico gas intestinal tapando todo.
Sí. Y te confieso, si yo estuviera ahí y no veo la piedra, mi
instinto me pediría más certeza antes de ser invasiva.
Yo querría pedir una colangioresonancia magnética para ver bien el mapa antes
de meterle un endoscopio a la paciente.
Porque esto es una pésima idea.
Porque esa búsqueda de certeza anatómica perfecta ignora el reloj biológico de la
sepsis.
Aquí las guías de la ASGE, la Sociedad Estadounidense de Endoscopia
Gastrointestinal, son claras.
¿Qué dicen?
Dicen que no necesitas ver la piedra si el contexto clínico es abrumador.
Esta paciente tiene una probabilidad pretest alta.
Tiene clínica de colangitis, bilirrubina de 6,4, que supera por mucho el
umbral de 4 miligramos
por decilitro, y tiene el colédoco dilatado.
O sea, la evidencia indirecta es tan fuerte que ver la piedra da igual.
Exacto.
El protocolo exige saltar imágenes adicionales e ir directo a la CPRE, la
colangiopancreatografía
retrógrada endoscópica.
Es una misión de
rescate físico. Entran, canalizan la vía y sacan la piedra.
Si pides una resonancia, pierdes horas en traslados y coordinación, y en una vía
cerrada e infectada, esas horas le dan la victoria a la translocación bacteriana.
Lo cual nos lleva al punto de quiebre de este análisis, y a la trampa donde muchos
caen. Ya tenemos el diagnóstico de colangitis aguda, pero ahora hay que
clasificar la gravedad para que sobreviva, y usamos los criterios de Tokio 2018.
Que están diseñados justo para ver si el fuego local ya pasó al resto del cuerpo.
Sí, y se dividen en tres pilares.
El pilar A es inflamación sistémica, que lo cumple
por los leucocitos de 17,800.
El pilar B es colestasis, que lo cumple por la bilirrubina
de 6,4. Y el pilar C es la imagen, que lo cumple por el colédoco
dilatado. Así que
es definitivo. Pero al graduar la gravedad, Tokio nos dice que es un grado 2,
una colangitis
moderada.
Claro, moderada porque cumple dos umbrales específicos, los leucocitos
mayores a 12,000 y la bilirrubina mayor o igual a 5.
Curioso que la fiebre de 38,9 roza, pero no alcanza el umbral
de 39 grados exactos para sumarle otro punto.
Sí, por eso se queda sólidamente en moderada.
Y aquí viene el error documentado de la residente a cargo esa madrugada.
Su plan fue, iniciamos ceftriaxona intravenosa, la
dejamos en observación 48 horas,
Y si mejora, programamos cirugía esta semana.
Ouch.
Y yo voy a ser de abogado del diablo.
Si estoy en un turno a las 3 de la mañana, ese plan me parece súper sensato.
O sea, la paciente está moderada, no está en choque.
Le doy antibióticos fuertes, la hidrato.
¿Para qué voy a despertar al endoscopista de guardia si no es tan grave?
Es que la palabra moderada te genera una falsa ilusión de seguridad letal.
El plan de la residente falla porque ignora la mecánica pura.
La mecánica de la obstrucción.
Claro, es como tapar el tubo de escape de un auto encendido.
Le puedes poner el mejor aceite sintético, que serían los antibióticos, pero
si los gases no tienen por dónde salir, la presión va a reventar el motor.
O sea, los antibióticos limpian la sangre, pero no destapan la tubería.
La ceftriaxona esteriliza la sangre un rato, pero la vía biliar sigue
siendo un absceso en un tubo cerrado.
El hígado empuja bilis, la presión intrabiliar aumenta, y esa presión
destruye la barrera mucosa.
Y ahí entran las bacterias millones de bacterias y endotoxinas
se inyectan a presión directo a la vena portal y al sistema
el antibiótico no puede con esa avalancha masiva por eso un grado
2 exige drenaje temprano en las primeras 24 a 48 horas
y el caso clínico ilustra esto brutalmente avanzamos
seis horas la residente aplicó su plan le dio antibiótico y dos
litros de cristaloides pero a las seis horas llega el choque
El choque con la realidad hemodinámica Literal.
La presión se desploma a 84 sobre 50 milímetros de mercurio
y ya no responde a líquidos.
La paciente está somnolienta.
Además, hace una oliguria severa, orina 20 mililitros en tres
horas y la creatinina salta a 2,3 miligramos por decilitro.
Es el costo predecible de ignorar la obstrucción.
La traslocación ganó y ahora está en choque séptico.
Ya no es grado 2 Pasó a falla multiorgánica Exacto.
Falla cardiovascular
por la hipotensión, neurológica por la somnolencia y renal por
la oliguria y creatinina. Ahora es un grado 3.
Colangitis severa.
El panorama cambió radicalmente.
Ya no hay observación prudente que valga.
Ante esto, ¿cuál es el protocolo de rescate?
Ingresó a UCI de inmediato. Probablemente vasopresores.
Y el drenaje biliar pasó de ser temprano a ser de extrema
urgencia.
Hay que destapar ese tubo de escape ya.
Con CPRE como primera línea.
Entras, haces esfinterotomía, que es un corte en el esfínter de Oddi, y sacas la
piedra, o pones un stent plástico para que salga el pus.
Pero a ver, seamos realistas. A veces la CPRE falla técnicamente, o en ese
hospital no hay equipo a esa hora. ¿Qué hacemos?
¿Cuál es el plan B?
Si no puedes entrar por abajo, el plan B es el drenaje biliar percutáneo
transhepático. Metes una aguja y un catéter por la piel y el hígado, directo a los
conductos biliares, y sacas esa presión.
¿Y si eso tampoco?
Drenaje guiado por ecoendoscopía.
El método da igual. El objetivo es descomprimir de inmediato.
Ahora, una duda que siempre surge en urgencias.
La ecografía decía que la vesícula estaba súper inflamada.
Si la paciente está tan grave, ¿no la metemos al quirófano a quitarle esa vesícula
de una vez?
No, hacer eso sería una distracción letal.
¿Por qué?
La vesícula está inflamada, sí, pero eso no es lo que la está matando ahora.
Lo que la tiene en choque es la vía biliar principal tapada.
Meter a una paciente inestable con falla renal y sin presión a una
Colecistectomía de urgencia es un error estratégico inmenso.
Claro, el riesgo quirúrgico es altísimo.
La vesícula pasa a segundo plano.
Solo hay que drenar el colédoco.
La colecistectomía se programa de forma electiva cuando ya salga del choque
séptico.
¡Qué buen análisis! Esto nos deja claro que no se trata de memorizar escalas,
sino de entender la física del cuerpo.
En una colangitis aguda, digamos que la presión biliar es el fármaco que hay que
bajar con más urgencia. El antibiótico apaga el fuego en la sangre, pero
el drenaje apaga la fuente.
Totalmente. Confiar solo en farmacología aquí es garantía de fracaso.
Para cerrar, quiero dejarle a quienes nos escuchan un escenario contrastante
que las guías ponen como advertencia final.
Imagina que te llega a consulta un hombre de 71 años.
Tiene mucha ictericia, pero no hay fiebre.
Leucocitos normales. Y lo más loco, no tiene nada de dolor.
Uh, bandera roja inmediata.
Además, dice que perdió 9 kilos en semanas.
Le palpas el abdomen y sientes una masa tensa en el hipocondrio derecho,
que es la vesícula gigante, pero no le duele nada al apretar.
El famoso signo de Courvoisier-Terrier.
Exactamente.
Ese cuadro te obliga a frenar en seco, ictericia progresiva,
pérdida de peso y vesícula palpable sin dolor.
Eso no es una piedra. Tienes que pensar en un adenocarcinoma de cabeza de
páncreas o un ampuloma.
Y la regla de oro aquí, según las guías, es contraintuitiva a lo que acabamos de
hablar. Advierten que jamás te apresures a poner un stent biliar a
ciegas antes de estadificar el tumor.
Claro, siempre y cuando sea resecable y no haya colangitis.
Exacto. Porque si le pones un stent prematuro, causas una
inflamación local severa que te arruina los planos anatómicos.
Y podrías complicar una cirugía oncológica que le hubiera curado la vida.
Es un recordatorio fascinante de que la vía biliar no perdona las decisiones en
piloto automático.
Siempre exige detenerse un segundo y preguntar, a ver, ¿qué es exactamente
lo que está obstruyendo esta tubería?
Ese es el verdadero arte clínico.